reveal the winner for the best
performance by an actor in a supporting
role the nominees are Charles Durning
for the best little whorehouse in Texas
Louis doctors jr. in an officer and a
gentleman
John let's go in the world according to
GARP
James Mason in the verdict
and Robert Preston in victor/victoria
funny Krista Tuesdays with women's is
could have been performed by women yeah
I guess you're trying to say that this
year is hospital is partly a drag race
oh okay don't is you better do that I
would be glad to thank very much
the winner is little gossip
you know when you prepare a speech
there's no use because it's all gone I
tried to get my kid to come up here to
share this with me
but there are some special people I
would like to share this with
specifically tomorrow is a 17th
anniversary of my relationship with my
one agent mr. ed Von D they say
marriages don't last I've got a spirit
that guides me starting from a
great-grandmother who died at the age of
117 and my mom and dad well I know we're
watching my cousin Yvonne thank you
you make everything fall into place and
all you are the four guys this is ours